[Musique]
ce nouveau désastre est un mélange
détonnant de drogue un dérivé puissant
de la cocaïne dans la moindre prise vous
rend immédiatement dépendant fin des
années 80 le crack arrive en france nous
ne sommes ni à brooklyn né dans le bronx
mais à paris en plein métro sur la ligne
numéro 9 devenu la ligne de la drogue
le crack se consomme donc à la vue de
tous dans le métro et dont certains
quartiers de la capitale
aujourd'hui on le vend au coeur de paris
sur un marché à ciel ouvert c'est une
place coquette au bord des canaux dans
le quartier on l'appelle la place du
crack
car chaque jour dès la fin de l'après
midi au vu et au su de tous le marché le
supermarché s'installe le supermarché la
place du crack c'est le quartier
stalingrad dans le nord-est de paris qui
devient la plaque tournante de ce
commerce dans la capitale scène
familière l'homme achète
puis ils consomment partout sur la place
sainte il est lueur des briquets lorsque
le caillou brûle dans les doseurs ceux
des habitués des prostituées des
boulevards extérieurs et même des
noctambules branché car le crack
commence à sortir de son ghetto la
drogue sort de son ghetto et dans les
années 90 le nombre de consommateurs
augmente une petite cinquantaine à paris
en 1991 un millier deux ans plus tard
parmi eux des héroïnomanes de longue
date mais plus inquiétant de jeunes
consommateurs n'ayant jamais utilisé de
drogue auparavant face à ce ballet les
toxicomanes et des dealers les riverains
n'en peuvent plus je suis toujours en
train de me retourner derrière moi parce
que j'ai peur pour ma graisse je veux
pas que mon bébé ils soient aidés dans
un quartier comme ça oui peut avoir des
risques d'insécurité et près de 20 ans
plus tard un début de solution pour
sortir la drogue de la rue après des
années de controverse une salle de shoot
comme on dit c'est à dire réservé aux
toxicomanes ouvre ses portes à paris en
2016 la première salle de shoot
française à paris dans le quartier de la
gare du nord sur place la drogue n'est
pas fournie on distribue le matériel
d'injection ou inhalation jetables
stérile gratuit les produits sont
consommés ici dans la salle d'injection
une salle de repos permet aux
consommateurs de ne pas repartir sous
l'effet des stupéfiants des salles de
shoot que la maire de paris anne hidalgo
voudrait multiplier dans la capitale un
moyen selon elle de résoudre la crise du
crack
[Musique]